нарешті наш захід по презентації
національної
школи керівників
Я рахую що відбудеться оскільки це вже
третя спроба ініціатива щодо створення
цієї школи було
ініційована міністром рік назад на
Харківській конференції 7 нот а
презентація цієї школи всі пригадують ми
її планували 24 лютого цього року але в
цей день розпочалася війна і презентація
була перенесена за цей час за ці 9
місяців ми
значно розширилися до нас доєднались
доєдналися багато нових партнерів в
рамках співпраці і створення школи
підписано 17 меморандумів і я хочу від
представити
провідних наших партнерів які сьогодні
беруть участь презентації цієї школи і
це Міністр освіти і науки Сергій шкарль
координаторка національної школи
управлінців доктор педагогічних наук
професор Наталія клокарі
заступника асоціації інноваційної та
цифрової освіти Дмитро Бондаренко
ексклюзивний партнер франклинкові
Education в Україні Олександр шибка
директор центрального і
Східноєвропейського
офісу Intel Skills for innovation Луїджі
пасіна президент міжнародного Союзу
директорів шкіл аріпока в записі
та генеральний директор
компанії Наталя піталова
Отже Шановні колеги до слова запрошую
міністра освіти і науки Сергія шкарпета
Доброго дня
шановні дорогі Мої колеги
вимушений міняти локацію оскільки
світла немає але це не яким чином не
зменшує актуальності і якості
сьогоднішнього закиду які Ну планувався
ще до початку війни Ми не можемо далі
тільки тягнути
цього проекту оскільки
новасвітня політика актуалізувала
проблему чи закладів освіти Ми
реалізуємо штатний проект з нашими
партнерами української школи президент
структурними
за методичними елементами Ми забули
вчителя забули в нас я з ним я
інформацію забули сайт того хто
забезпечує якістю освіти адже відомий
прислів що якість учня не буде більшою
ніж якість вчителя сьогодні актуалізує
проблему національної школи управлінців
лідерів
головну мету яку ми з вами в цілому
закладали в реалізацію цього проекту є
пошук і формалізація новий генерації
керівників
лідерів які наповнені інноваційним
змістом творчим змістом які готові до
змін і здатні забезпечити якими
функціонування закладів освіти відділу
освіти об'єднаної територіальної громади
області Департаменту освіти і науки
Міністерстві освіти і науки таких
лідерів вкрай потрібно на сьогодні
національна школа управління цим лідерів
- це своєрідна платформа інструмент який
об'єднує узагальнює найкраще
управлінський світовий досвід недаремно
сьогодні присутні серед наших колег ціла
низка іноземних експертів які
забезпечують нам у методичну методичну
підтримку і дає можливість нам
ознайомитись з найсучаснішими
тенденціями і програмами в освіті ми з
вами їздимо маємо можливість онлайн
спілкуватись з нашими колегами
найуспішнішими управлінцями в галузі
освіти з України Сполучених Штатів
Америки Фінляндії Британії Японія
Нідерландів Чехії всі країни Євросоюзу
та інших наших колег недаремно на форумі
в івано-франківську ми обговорювали саме
проблему з-під цю міністрами освіти щодо
управлінців лідерів галузі освіти так
найактуальніша проблема я виступав серед
і сьогодні в тому числі
і Тиждень тому виступав серед міністрів
освіти країни Європейського Союзу і саме
проблема національної школи управлінців
лідерів є в голову кута поставлене
завдання Сьогодні для врятування освіти
для переформатування освіти для
формування освіти 4:0 освіти 5:0 в
залежності від того як буде рухатись
технологічно світ наше завдання Сьогодні
у створити умови і можливості
реалізувати потенціал кожного бажаючого
підтримка потенційних лідерів серед
педагогів фахівців і формування нової
генерації керівників це професійне
становлення новопризначених директорів
шкіл це підвищення кваліфікації
досвідчених керівників з урахуванням
Світового освітнього досвіду абсолютно
впевнений що успіх та ефективні
діяльності будь-якого навчального
закладу зелене все від Києва
сучасний керівник перш за все лідерком
здатний особа яка здатна об'єднати
навколо себе найкраще і створити дітям
найкращі умови навчання існування
власних конкурентів і
ліду має будувати лікар через повторюю
так само як і на
[музика]
Проблема була зі з'єднанням тоді
Дякуємо
своєю Миколайовичу за
настанову за вступне слово
щодо відкриттів
[музика]
педагогічних наук професору заслуженому
працівнику освіти України Наталії блок
пані Наталя будь ласка запрошую вас
вітаю всіх учасників презентації
надзвичайно приємно бачити що у вас всіх
і нас об'єднує дійсно дуже гарне Місія
це робота із управлінцями галузі освіти
відповідно користуючись нагодою хочу
подякувати міністра освіти і науки
України Сергія шкарлута заступника
міністра віру рогову і директор
інституту модернізації змісту освіти
Євгена боженкова за
ініціативою за злагоджену командну
роботу щодо створення От такої
національної школи управлінців яка є на
часі Оскільки ми з вами розуміємо що
будь-які новації в освіті мо організація
її змісту і структури у значній мірі
залежить від рівня компетентності
керівників закладів освіти саме тому ми
ставимо за завдання об'єднати в єдину
систему напрями роботи із керівниками як
такі перша це робота з підготовки
резерву управлінських кадрів і
розроблена цілісна програма з декількох
модулів яка дає можливість майбутнім
керівникам проявити своє лідерські
задатки і претендувати на посади
директорів шкіл по закінченню навчання у
нашій школі наступний напрям - це робота
і знову призначеними директорами І ми
успішно тут працюємо із нашими
партнерами свійського проекту і звичайно
що подальша підтримка в наших
професійних директорів директорів
лідерів яких ми плануємо і вже починаємо
залучати до процесу стажування яке буду
проходити наше майбутнє керівники
закладів освіти тобто ось ці напрямки
дають можливість нам сьогодні говорити
про
це єдиної цілісної системи професійного
розвитку підтримки керівників закладів
освіти звичайно хочу акцентувати що наша
робота будується на добровільності і
структура і зміст нашого навчання і
майбутніх керівників закладів освіти і
звичайно працюючих директорів
зосереджений на мобільності на
доступності на врахування всіх тих умов
яких сьогодні працює освіта звичайно
наші курси адаптивні оскільки вони дають
можливість кожного слухачу вибирати те
що їм до душі те що вони бажають те що
найбільше цікавить той чи іншого слухача
звичайно приємно що до нашої ідеї
долучились наші зарубіжні партнери
партнери які сьогодні максимально
підтримують Україну в усіх напрямах і в
освіті Зокрема я щиро дякую нашим
партнерам про яких ви ще говорив
Шановний пан Євген
ми успішно розпочали роботу із
корпорацією Intel схил свої novation
Дякую пану Луїджі який буде сьогодні
говорити провели навчання гломовних
тренінгів для наших слухачів і
підготували 12 тренерів які будуть
працювати на теренах України в кожному
регіоні Дякую корпорації франкінг
Україні нашими фінським партнерам фонду
освітньої ініціатив stem-освіта і на
часі у нас Нові горизонти і нова
співпраця ми намагаємось бути сучасними
і мобільними тому готуємо новий зміст і
нові модулі з нашими чеськими партнерами
із нашими польськими партнерами робота
цікава робота потрібна і якщо будуть
запитання у наших присутніх Я готова
дати там відповіді щодо змісту того чи
іншого модуля а власне Дякую за
підтримку всім причетним і нашим
проблемним партнером нашим вітчизняним
провідним науковців і практикам які
розпочали роботу у нашій школі
національній школі управлінських кадрів
Я впевнена що школа матиме успіх і на
місцях в регіонах наші освітяни відчують
нашу реальну підтримку Дякую за увагу
Дякую Наталія Іванівна Дякую за вашу
роботу яку ви ведете по коорди по
координації
всіх наших партнерів по наповненню цього
ресурсу
Дякуємо вам наступного наступним до
слова запрошується Олександр шибка
ексклюзивне партнер Франклін Кові
еducation в Україні пане Олександр вас
до слова запрошення будь ласка
Євгене Шановні колеги учасники глядачі
Сергій Миколайович в першу чергу
Дозвольте від усієї американської
корпорації франкенкові подякувати
міністерству та міністру особисто за
запрошення нас долучитися у створенні
національної школи управлінської окремо
подяка нашій українській команді на чолі
стані Гордієнко за локалізацією та
синхронізацію нашого компоненту наш
компонент у національній школі
управлінців за академія керів закладу
освіти це навчальна програма
використовується компанія У більш ніж
6000 школах на всіх п'яти континентах у
73 країн вона є виключно для керівників
закладів освіти за посадою і покликана
змінити парадигму управління як лідера
як підхід до управління керівництва
школи компанія вивела чотири загальні
проблеми які стоять перед школами у
світі це не ясна ціль візія та стратегія
бюрократія та непоєднані системи
нерозкриті таланти та потенціал все Це
веде до низької довіри
академія керівника закладу освіти це
синтезоване рішення для рішення цих
проблем за допомогою максимального
ефективного інструментів А на виході
готова дорожня карта поїхати
імплементації у себе в школі що я хотів
би підкреслити з нашого боку 21 вересня
21-го року ми підписали договір щодо
співпраці та взаємодії і для вперше в
світі для вчителів державних школах
стала можлива підготовка вчителів з
лідерським підходом Френк клинкові а
саме соціальне емоційний навчання для
розкриття потенціалу школярів і сьогодні
вперше в світі Міністерство освіти і
науки робить можливим для директорів
державних саме в державних школах
опанувати найбільш ефективні інструменти
для лідерського управління школи у нашій
більш ніж 23-літні історії надання
рішень преміум класу для освітнього
сектору це безпрецедентний лідерський
підхід для управління освітою на
найвищому державному рівні ми щиро
вдячні пану міністру пану євгену за цей
справжній підхід державницький для
розвитку нашого якісного покоління
покоління Перемоги наших молодих
українців щиро вдячний Дякую за увагу
Дякую пане Олександру Дякую йому за те
що ми ефективно співпрацюємо вже другий
рік і за те що українські
педагоги українські директори шкіл Мають
доступ до унікальної системи до якої
мають доступ сьогодні понад 140 країн
світу і в рамках нашого партнерства Ми
продовжуємо роботу Дякую вам
шановні друзі наступним до слова Я хочу
запросити директора центрального і
східноєвропейської офісу компанії Intel
Skills for innovation
Луїджі песина будь ласка
Луїджі запрошуємо вас до слова
[музика]
симпатиті
Ukrainian from
aninta сайт
[музика]
до інформатичного
війни України
[музика]
Дякую вам пане луіджи Шановні колеги я
хочу надати слово
заступнику голови асоціації інноваційної
та цифрової освіти Дмитро Бондаренко без
участі цієї асоціації неможливо було б
реалізувати технічні можливості і
технічне навчання
засобами онлайн і Дмитро будь ласка
запрошуємо вас до слова Доброго дня дуже
радий всіх чути і бачити нам дуже
почесне що саме наші організації довіри
створює такої платформи Як школа
національну школу управлінців спільно з
компанією чар-ю сподіваюсь ми зробили
дуже цікавий корисний і легко легкий
продукт який буде дуже зручно
користуватися це не просто сайт це
повноцінна System тобто ВМС яка дозволяє
зручно та
коректно навчатись і
Весь процес навчання можна побачити тут
отже презентуємо і представляємо наш
платформу звичайно Як ви вже знаєте
навчання можуть відбуватися
офлайн форматі Тобто безпосередньо
в інститути модернізації змісту освіти
але також для зручності можна навчатись
і дистанційно на нашій платформі Отже ми
бачимо що у нас на сьогоднішній день вже
є дві програми всього їх буде багато там
7-10 Можливо навіть бути далі
розвиватись але треба буде пройти 5 з
них щоб отримати
повну завершення цього курсу зараз вже є
дві програми які сьогодні в доступі
кожна з них це по одному кредиту тобто
по 30 годин Отже перша програма це
навчання резерву управлінських кадрів
галузі освіти і друга програма яка вже у
доступі це програма лідеру мені
партнерів компанії які сьогодні вже
переді мною презентували виступали Отже
якщо можна далі будь ласка
як навчатись досить легкі 7 кроків і на
сайті є підказка якщо хтось забуде
подивитись ще раз Отже крок це
зареєструватись другий крок це обирати
програму як я вже казав що всього
потрібно буде вибирати 5 програм з 7 а
потім і збільшує кількості але зараз
доступні дві Я думаю поки дві будуть
наші Шановні колеги проходити і учасники
школи управлінців для інше програми
також будуть розміщені вже і будуть у
доступі третій крок - це
потрібно безпосередньо пройти ту частину
програми яка є онлайн на сайті це як
правило ми робимо у мультимедійному
форматі з корм на відміну від звичайних
відео лекцій він набагато краще
засвоюється є вже
певні досліди міжнародних в тому числі
американських структур провідних які
говорять що при звичайних відеоуроках
відео лекціях на шостій хвилині впадає
падає концентрація на
60%, тобто вже на шостій хвилині
відеолекції освітнього спрямування
становиться неефективними на їх зміну
прийшли якраз формат з конкурсів який
навпаки дозволяє весь час навчання
тримати увагу концентрацію людини яка
навчається як саме ми покажемо трохи
пізніше
Отже четвертий крок треба взяти буде
участь у вебінарі який буде
складова частина цього
ці програми або виконати домашнє
завдання Сьогодні ми з вами подивимось
що є І такі І такі варіанти далі
попрацювати інформацію для самостійного
навчання яку нам нададуть фахівці при
проходженні цього курсу
і остання - це
після успішного проходження певних
кроків треба буде зробити оплату за
користування сервісом тобто не за
програма за саме за сервісом і тільки
тоді можна завершити навчання
і отримати індивідуальний сертифікат з
унікальним номером який публічно буде
вивішений на сайті так і на цьому сайті
Card буде внесений у єдину базу тому він
буде мати унікальний номер завжди можна
перевірити або підтвердити його
валідність Ось такі сім кроків
легкі але зручні але ті які дозволяють
проходити навчання про партнерів
сьогодні вже казали тому не буду
повторюватись Ми дякуємо дійсно
Міністерство освіти Дякуємо інститут
модернізації змісту освіти ще раз кажу
про це що довірили нам з компанією
створити такий портал для наших шановних
керівників навчальних закладів Отже
тепер якщо можна піднятись наверх і ще
трохи інформації з функціоналу нашого
порталу
якщо можна інформації є Про нас можна
подивитися
що собою являє національна школа
управлінців далі будь ласка
експерти ви можете подивитися хто саме
викладає як провідні українські фахівці
так і От наприклад пані саммерс - Це
вчителька в США Яка єдина в історії США
двічі ставала вчителькою року і вона
якраз з проектом французької сьогодні
тут представлена
пан пока він також буде сьогодні
виступати серед учасників відомий для
українських
освітян вже фахівець Фінляндії з однією
з провідних систем освіти в світі і
звичайно на українській фахівці які
також провідні взяли участь у створенні
програми у кожному з них може бути
побачити до якого курсу вони
безпосередньо приклали свою руку
далі будь ласка
так контакти звичайно якщо ви хочете
звернутись є оперативний зв'язок через
дані про безпосередньо розробника цього
проекту Ви можете написати питання дуже
швидко отримати відповідь далі будь
ласка
Отже особистий кабінет Дякую ми перейшли
до нього ви бачите що тут стандартна
інформація заповнюється це потрібно для
того щоб ідентифікувати людину яка
проходить той чи інший курс і внести ці
дані безпосередньо сертифікат
цей документ дуже легко може
доповнюватися або змінюватися будь ласка
продемонструю я Як це можна робити
натискаємо просто на своє ім'я і
прізвище і бачимо що можна перейти до
редагування будь-яких даних далі будь
ласка
далі будь ласка що можна Да є
оскільки як ми казали що це управління
проектами то є ціллю є цілий Розділ де
можна побачити Які курси саме проходять
ви бачите зараз наприклад ця людина
проходить курси два два уроки і є
прогрес видно скільки вона пройшла Це
дуже добре і дуже потрібне якщо людина
починала потім зупинилась через якийсь
час продовжував Вона не повинна
згадувати що вона пройшла ще ні все він
на всі чітко все є саме керування
навчанням кожна людина в особистому
кабінеті будь ласка далі
мої вебінари - це розділ безумовно
записи на вебінарі ви бачите що зараз
записана в вебінар вже людина буде
відвідувати вебінар в рамках курсу це
дуже знову ж таки зручно є нагадування і
тут можна в Google Календар одразу
перенести якщо потрібно тобто абсолютно
зручна така підказочка в якій вебінари у
людини чекає людина виправити далі будь
ласка
це список тих
майбутніх сертифікатів які людина буде
отримувати Як я вже казав треба буду
отримати 5 з того набору програм які
буде запропонований щоб повністю
завершити школа кожен з сертифікату це
буде один кредит Тобто можна зупинитись
на 1 2 3 4 на будь-якій кількості
людина захоче проходити далі будь ласка
Я думаю ми безпосередньо можемо перейти
до програм як я казав вже готові дві ось
ви бачите і знов таки ви бачите прогрес
кожної людини буде свій прогрес він в
куту в процентному відношенні щоб одразу
згадати зрозуміти на якому питання на
якому місці людина зупинилася Отже
подивимось 1 освітню програму тут якраз
друга частина її буде безпосередньо що
можна зайдемо у середину друга частина
безпосередньо буде тут вебінар саме той
вебінар на який ми записались ви бачите
ось в даному випадку є опис програми
дуже зручно і зрозуміло людина може
ознайомитись перед тим як обрати ту чи
іншу програму що вона в себе включає які
саме модулі на які теми бачите тут всі
модулі і є вебінар для того щоб
завершити повністю курс зловина вебінар
можна записатись дуже легко давайте
продемонструємо Як це зробити
перейдемо до запису на вебінар
і оберемо ви бачите що підказка є Що у
вівторок 17 січня відбудеться вебінар
саме за цим курсом Отже ми можемо
записатись час визначено і таким чином у
вас з'явиться в вашому обліковому
кабінеті запис на цей вебінар Дякую і
другий курс будь ласка покажемо там у
нас замість вебінару бути домашні
завдання це також вказана у курсі який
ми зможемо зараз побачити літеру мені
будь ласка опис тут 8
онлайн-уроків і після цього є
вимога до виконання домашнього завдання
в якому форматі що саме повинні бути і
на які email його для перевірки потрібно
відправити після проходження всіх 8
років після виконання домашнього
завдання і перевірки Ви також отримаєте
автоматично ваш кабінет сертифікат
Дякую І я думаю що цей проект буде
цікавим і хочу побажати всім успішного
навчання дякую дякую за коментар А зараз
я прошу Включити
запис генерального директора президента
міжнародного Союзу директорів шкіл
аріпока який до нас звернувся і записав
відеозвернення дякую
Дорогі колеги в Україні сьогодні Мені
дуже приємно взяти участь у
принципі щодо нової української школи
мені дуже приємно що ви створили нову
платформу для українських директорів
шкіл і я сподіваюся що саме це вам
потрібно і це дійсно за допомогою
задовольнити потреби багатьох директорів
шкіл в Україні і директор відіграє дуже
важливу роль в школі вирішальну роль у
школі і така людина яка є директором
школи має бути людина яка вчиться все
своє життя таким чином щоб забезпечити
безперервність освіти і ще не залежить
від його де людина знаходиться якого
вона віку і активне навчання і вивчення
матеріалу це така роль яку виконують
учні вчителі це питання не тільки ваших
компетентності навичок але тут дуже
важливо
втілення основної ідеї яку має школа мак
треба бути активними
людьми що навчаються і так само ви
повинні навчатися Як ви очікуєте ваші
учні будуть навчатися і дуже багато
директорів стоять перед величезними
викликами особливо в Україні зараз і
директори працюють поміж баченням і
практикою директор школи повинен знати
основні цілі національної освітньої
політики і розуміти в той же час яким
чином
на практиці здійснити Всі речі у своїй
власній школі і ця роль вимагає дуже
багатьох зусиль і дуже багато хто з нас
навіть найкраще повинні весь час
відновлювати свої навички свою практику
свої знання і звичайно
і
Ми повинні шукати рішення практичні
рішення викликів які стоять перед нами і
нам дуже важливо розуміти що є певна
політика яку ми маємо впроваджувати для
того щоб здійснити наше бачення інакше
ви можете власне працювати повсякденно
але не будете
розуміти цілі своєї власної роботи і
завжди у директори є лідерами лідерами
впровадження цінності і цінності це наші
віхи
вихованні нового покоління українців і
особливо зараз це дуже важливо і ваша
наступне покоління буде відновлювати
Україну буде будувати нову Україну і ця
робота буде дуже практично і звичайно ми
повинні ставити цілі і
цією роботою І власне базувати її на
цінностях звичайно школа і директор
школи буде тим маяком яке дає напрямок
руху всієї організації і хороша робота
завжди вимагає хорошого планування
Звичайно потрібно все встановлювати
довгострокові цілі і щорічні плани і
освіта це не просто імпровізація чи
життя в одній якісь хвилині звичайно
іноді треба бути іноді гнучким але треба
виконувати плани і мати хорошу структуру
роботи для того щоб втілити ваші
завдання належним чином ваші плани
повинні відповідати потребам вашій
громади і вашої школи і тоді ми можемо
говорити про автономну школу і це таку
школу яка буде унікальною і ви зробите
цю школу унікальною І на завершення
Я хотів би сказати що дуже важливо дбати
про благополуччя ваших учнів і вчителів
і я певен що
лучше буде однією з основних тем в
українській системі освіти і
благополуччя починається із управління
кризовими ситуаціями і закінчується
навіть задоволенням особливих потреб і
написанням планів
впровадження такого благополуччя не
тільки учнів але і учителі і самого
директора і я розумію що це буде
відбирати у вас дуже багато енергії дуже
багато часу в наступні роки і ми будемо
набагато вам в цьому завданні і дорогі
українські колеги ситуація
в якій ви зараз керуєте своїми школою
має дуже багато викликів і звичайно вам
треба розумітися з моїми колегами і
звичайно
скористайтеся тією можливістю яка зараз
у вас існує
в рамках цих наших вебінарів створіть
свою власну спільноту директорів шкіл
найкращим другом директора школи є інший
директор школи і ми дуже добре розуміємо
в чому полягає наша робота і Перед якими
викликами ми стаємо і тому найкраще
вислухаємо ваші потреби і найкращим
чином вам допоможемо Коли така допомога
вам знадобиться І от я сподіваюся що
наші тренінги були корисними і ми
проводили їх на основі співпраці як
завжди я хотів би підкреслити що
навчання це будуть це з двостороннім
рухом і її
і такий двосторонній рух таке
двостороннє навчання на збагачує І я
хотів би побажати вам всього найкращого
і успіхів на
в роботі на платформі віддаленого
навчання
Ми дуже дякуємо за такі теплі слова за
[музика]
і ми
відкриваємо в Україні
поки якого знають сотні наших вчителів і
директорів в Україні і постійно теж
відчуваємо його особисто підтримку До
речі національна школа управлінців вона
не тільки для керівників закладів
загальної середньої освіти ця школа
можуть їй можуть користуватися і
керівники закладів дошкільної освіти і я
хочу до слова запросити генерального
директора компанії Містер лідер це
інноваційна сучасна нова програма яка
пройшла експертизу Міністерстві освіти
отримала гриф рекомендовано і як пора
величезну популярність в країні Я
запрошую до слова Наталія піканова нам
розкаже і найближчим часом До речі Ця
програма буде доступна вже
в самій школі
пані Наталя будь ласка
Дуже дякую пане Євгена за слово скажіть
будь ласка чи чутно Мене видно Добре все
нормально
щодня Дуже дякую Отже якщо мені якщо
можна Да На жаль демонструвати екран не
можу тому буду говорити словами Да
трошки розповім про те що ж таке наша
система
[музика]
почну з того що це система вона є
унікальною достатньо тому що іноваційною
і ми не будемо так казати тому що
насправді
ми можемо да
цю систему Вона може бути на будь-якому
вашому гаджеті у будь-якому вашому
смартфоні телефонні комп'ютері або смарт
телевізорі і ви можете нею Абсолютно
безкоштовно користуватися і Наразі я
хочу подякувати да інституту
модернізації змісту освіти у чудову
співпрацю і що ми можемо рухатися разом
і як то кажуть творити да інноваційні
речі і розвивати як дошкільну освіту так
і ранній розвиток в Україні
скажу одразу що ця система була
побудована на основі філософської ідеї
пана Володимира Воронова який є
да автором ідеї скажімо і вся філософія
його книги про лідерство закладене в
основу нашої системи чому називаємо це
система тому що вона насправді дуже
багато компонентна включає як базову
програму Це є моніторинг знань і
орієнтовно щоденне планування Вже готове
на кожен день Да рекомендації з
харчування для батьків безліч методичних
та дидактичних матеріалів рекомендації
для батьків з освіти дітей і звісно
Наразі це будуть курси підвищення
кваліфікації для керівників да та
педагогів дошкільної освіти в кінці
трошки пізніше про це скажу ще Да
анонсую це І все Це звісно наразі Слава
Богу онлайн да І ми маємо якщо є
інтернет і світло то маємо доступ до
цього наразі нашої системи вже
користується більше 24 тисяч
користувачів І звісно не можу поділитися
цим що це більше ніж в 49 країнах світу
ви знаєте що в наші дітки вони зараз
Поїхали за кордон наразі не завжди мають
доступ до дошкільної освіти а система
настільки проста що ви можете вдома
користуватися Да з дитиною як в батьки
просто так і в дошкільному закладі
педагоги дай ви можете це надати своїм
керівникам і вони цим також можуть
користу
без проблем і звісно Ось так виглядає ця
система Да є це є електронне планування
можете реєструватися заходити дивитись
але звісно найкраще для того щоб це
запровадити Буквально через 2-3 тижні
будуть готові повністю курс
да на освітній платформі яка була
анонсована і ви зможете як керівник
закладу пройти цей курс Да поринути у цю
філософію як то скажімо почати
користуватися інноваційними технологіями
і Відповідно ми до цього да скажімо
будемо дуже раді якщо ви будете
доєднуватися Тим паче що вже цієї
системи користуються певні заклади Але
після проходження курсу Я думаю що ви
дуже легко зможете інтегрувати систему
дуже швидко і легко до закладу тому
відповідно буквально Як то кажуть перед
Новим роком да як то кажуть у передріччі
новорічних свят зможете долучатися і
відповідно це буде я думаю чудовим да
скажімо чудовими знаннями для керівників
які зможуть в цьому брати участь тож Я
дуже сподіваюся скажімо Як то кажуть і
на співпрацю і на долучення і ще раз
хочу подякувати за пану євгену
Міністерство освіти інституту
модернізації за таку чудову співпрацю ви
найкращі Тож як то кажуть Слава Україні
і тримаємось на зв'язку
дякую пані Наталя Героям слава у нас
гарна новина у нас з'явився світ у нас
з'явився Інтернет
і ще у нас Кращий настрій і до нас
надійшло багато питань і таких два
найцікавіших питання Я хочу задати
одне пані Наталі клокарі пані Наталя ви
з нами Ви готові відповісти
Дякую
Да надійшло питання чи плануються ще
програми окрім тих які були сьогодні
представлені Якщо так яка процедура
подачі
Ми запрошуємо до співпраці всіх бажаючих
У кого є дійсно цікаві підходи
інноваційні проекти ми готові розглядати
відповідно і через члену Раду зміст
запропонованих матеріалів і розробляти
спільноте як ми працюємо із попередніми
партнерами спільно програми підвищення
кваліфікації хочу
і відповідно впроваджувати їх через нашу
національну школу Хочу зазначити що у
нас уже готовий до завантаження нові
модулі це модуль який стосується
психології управління закладом загальної
середньої освіти сучасних умовах
оскільки це надзвичайно важливо модуль
якийсь буде розкривати особливості
навчання дітей з особливими освітніми
потребами тобто інклюзивна освіта там в
цьому модулі 30-го майже 7 тем
також
актуальним є модуль інформаційно цифрова
компетентність керівників закладів
освіти впровадження
і дистанційного навчання це те що на
часі і готове до власне завантаження на
платформу і знову ж таки повторююсь ми
готові продовжувати і готувати нові за
змістом модулі оскільки життя змінюється
є нові виклики і ми плануємо оперативно
реагувати на запити освітян
дякую пані Наталя Дякую за вичерпну
відповідь я думаю що питань протягом
розвитку цієї системи буде ще більше і
відповіді будуть на ці питання а друге
питання Шановні колеги я хотів би задати
дмитру Бондаренко Дмитро ви з нами Ви
чуєте нас так Так
ми вас бачимо
питання наступне якщо обрати навчання на
платформі чи можна спочатку пройти
вебінар а вже потім онлайн курси
системна дуже гнучка як я вже казав в
самому початку не знаю чи був я почути
чи ні це льольник майже не слідством
тобто система яка управляє процесом
навчання тому можна спочатку пройти
повністю онлайн уроки а потім вебінар
або виконати домашнє завдання можна
зробити навпаки спочатку виконати
домашнє завдання або пройти вебінар а
потім завершити років можна розпочати
уроки пройти вебінар і завершити їх все
це відображається в особистому кабінеті
який сьогодні моя колега Оксана
показувала в особистому кабінеті тобто
все це можливо дуже гнучко дуже зручно
дуже зроблено так щоб будь-якій людині
було зручно будь-якій ситуації
дякуємо вам за відповідь я шановні друзі
Шановні колеги Шановні глядачі я хочу
подякувати всім нашим сьогоднішнім
спікером автором
міністру ініціатору цієї школи за участь
за презентацію за підготовку цих
матеріалів і насамкінець я хочу сказати
що якщо ти хочеш стати найкращим та
найуспішнішим хочеш розлунати лідерські
якості та реалізувати свій потенціал
тоді тебе до до Національної школи
управлінців Запрошуємо Дякую за увагу
шановні друзі і до зустрічі Спасибі всім